嘿，你最近有沒有聽說沙烏地阿拉伯在電動車市場的最新動作？我覺得這件事挺有意思的，有點出乎意料。
嗯，你說的是他們那個新的電動車品牌 Ceer Motors 嗎？我大概看了一下，聽說他們的主權基金同時也是美國 Lucid 的大股東，這點是讓我有點疑問啦，怎麼會讓兩家有競爭關係的公司都跟自己有這麼深的連結？
對，就是這個。一般企業當然會想避免內部競爭，但沙烏地的主權基金，也就是 PIF，這次的做法好像完全不一樣。他們不但持有 Lucid 大約 58% 的股份，還同時創立了 Ceer Motors。這兩家車廠，其實都鎖定在「高階」電動車市場。
等等，這裡我有疑問。你說鎖定高階市場？那不就等於自己跟自己打對台嗎？原文有提到這兩家產品的具體比較嗎？不然我會覺得這策略有點矛盾。
有提到喔。Ceer 推出的 Exobot 房車和 SUV，它們的高階版本馬力能超過 1,100 匹。而 Lucid 最快的車款 Air Sapphire 房車，馬力是 1,234 匹。你看，這兩者的性能其實非常接近，很明顯就是定位在同一個區塊。
哇，那這個競爭是實打實的。那他們具體是怎麼做到的？總不能說想做就做吧，這背後總得有更深層的考量，不然一個資本怎麼會讓自己的兩隻手互打？成本不划算吧？
其實原文有提到，PIF 的策略是把 Ceer Motors 定位成「本土的工業生態系統」。Lucid 雖然是豪華電動車公司，但它畢竟是美國公司，工廠主要在亞利桑那州。而 Ceer 的設計、工程甚至製造，都是在沙烏地當地進行，廠址就在 King Abdullah 經濟城。
我明白了，所以它不只是「造車」，而是要「造產業鏈」。但這模式撐得久嗎？Lucid 今年股價跌了超過 60%，而且在沙烏地本身的銷售量也大幅下滑了 57%。如果主力投資的 Lucid 都表現不佳，Ceer 又要跟它打對台，這投資風險會不會太高？
這點其實不容易做到，但 PIF 對 Lucid 的支持並沒有動搖。原文有說，沙烏地政府還簽訂了一份協議，未來十年要採購多達 10 萬輛 Lucid 的車。這其實說明了，即使 Lucid 短期表現不理想，他們還是有長期佈局的。
這樣說起來，對 PIF 來說，Lucid 可能是他們的全球市場佈局，而 Ceer 則是用來強化本土產業和技術自主性。如果我是創業者，這會給我什麼啟發呢？我總不能也同時做兩個相互競爭的產品線吧？
嗯，這個案例提醒我們，大型資本在看市場的時候，眼光會更廣。它不是在看單一品牌賺多少，而是看整個「產業生態系」的價值。對中小企業主來說，我們也許可以思考，有沒有可能透過異業整合或多品牌戰略，去覆蓋不同的市場區隔，即使這些區隔看起來有點重疊。
你是說，不是去避免競爭，而是去「設計競爭」嗎？像如果我開咖啡店，我可能會考慮在附近開一家特色甜點店，雖然都會賣飲料，但目標客群和主要賣點不同。
沒錯，就像你說的，設計競爭。它不是要你直接抄襲自己，而是要你思考，如何從不同的角度去滿足同一個市場的需求，或者透過不同品牌去測試市場反應，降低單一品牌失敗的風險。
那一般上班族能學到什麼？總不能讓自己的部門跟其他部門競爭吧？
哈哈，當然不是這樣。但這個概念可以讓我們思考，在工作中，我們是不是總避免衝突，或者總想著一個最佳解？有時候，或許可以試著從不同的方案、不同的角度去切入問題，甚至刻意讓兩個看似會衝突的方案並行一段時間，去觀察哪一個效益更高。
也就是說，不要被既定的「避免內部競爭」的觀念限制住。有時候，引入良性競爭，反而能激發出更多潛力或更全面的策略。
沒錯。畢竟沙烏地這兩個車廠的總產能目標，是國內市場需求的十倍以上。原文就指出，八成以上的產出都會是出口導向。所以國內市場只是個練兵場，他們真正的目標是更廣大的國際市場。
所以這不僅是沙烏地自己的 EV 產業鏈，也是他們擴展影響力的一種方式，而且還能確保風險不會集中在單一品牌上。
對，就是這個意思。這種策略，好像也提醒了我們，有時候放眼未來，看到更大的格局，比糾結眼前的局部競爭更重要。